♪
N
REEN  BHE RT AEME U WDRKITOE A
OK ATHE BGEST SUP BOWPRS.
THAT RIG.I' CONR ROGSALONIDEREG.
U MA KNO U AS E RULAR
UADOD DUO, T CW TH
TALKTO Y EVE SUNYND WEEOOKIOR UN
ORES
WE HE F.
GREGIVESTUFF AND,
HAD , BSR  , W GALUTEEOMHING TO
MAKE THIS EXTRA SPECIAL AND WE
NEED A GOOD FRIEND AND A NFL
LEGEND AND A SUPER BOWL CHAMPION
AND THERE HE IS, AQIB TALIB.
WHAT'S UP, MAN?
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> IT'S SUPER BOWL WEEK.
LET'S GET IT?
>> AQIB, I'LL THROW ONE AT YOU
RIGHT AWAY.
WE'RE COMING OFF TWO CONFERENCE
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND ONE SURPRISING
AND ONE MAYBE NOT.
LET'S GET INTO IT?
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CINCINNATI
BENGALS?
>> I AM.
FIRST, LET ME SAY THIS.
I THINK THE NFL IS THE MOST
COMPETITIVE IT'S BEEN SINCE I'VE
BEEN A PART OF IT, MAN.
THAT'S -- IT'S 14, 15 YEARS.
SO I'M KIND OF SURPRISED AND I
DID EXPECT THE TEAM TO WIN AND
IT WENT TO KANSAS CITY AND BEAT
THEM BOYS.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU ARE
RIDING WITH THE RAMS OR IF YOU
WERE RIDING WITH THOSE BENGALS
FOR THE UPSET.
THE MOST FUN WAY TO MAKE MONEY
IS TO BET ON AS MANY PROPS AS
YOU CAN EVEN IF YOU'RE JUST OUT
HERE SPRINKLING A FEW BUCKS
HAVING FUN AND GETTING IN ON
THOSE PROPS AND WE'RE ABOUT TO
GIVE YOU THE FIRST LOOK AT 40.
THAT IS RIGHT.
YOU HEARD ME, 40 FAVORITE DRAFT
KINGS, BIG GAME PROPS AND GREG,
WITH 40 PROPS COMES GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND GREAT
GIVEAWAYS.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT FOR THEM
TODAY?
>> CONNOR, WHAT AREN'T WE GIVE
AWAY?
WE HAVE CUSTOM BOOST FROM OUR
FRIENDS AT DRAFT KINGS AND SHOUT
OUT TO THEM AND OVER A THOUSAND,
CONNOR, OVER A THOUSAND DK
DOLLARS AND JERSEY, OF COURSE,
HOODIES AND AN iPHONE 13.
AQIB, I DON'T EVEN HAVE A 13.
DO YOU HAVE A 13?
>> I HAVEN'T GONE TO THE STORE
YET.
>> I HAVE TO GET TO THE STORE,
AND THEY HAVE THE 13S OUT, BUT
THE PRODUCERS ARE TELLING ME TO
GIVE AWAY SOMETHING RIGHT NOW.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
THIS RIGHT HERE IS THE HANDY
DANDY iPAD AND THIS IS HOW YOU
GET THE D.K. DOLLARS AND THIS IS
HOW YOU GET IT HERE IN THIS iPAD
AND I'M IN HERE LOOKING FOR A
TAKE AND SHOUT OUT TO B.R.
BETTING, BUT I SEE FRIDA
FELLCHER SAYS 38-30 BEPGAGENGALD
GAVE US A PREDICTION, AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVEN'T BEEN SAYING
THE BENGALS AND I LIKE WHAT THEY
DID AND SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
>> THE HANDY DANDY iPAD IS LIKE
GOING TO THE BANK ESPECIALLY
TONIGHT IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR
YOU BE SURE TO CHECK OUT DRAFT
KINGS TO WIN A $3 MILLION BET.
THAT'S RIGHT.
DRAFT KINGS IS GIVING AWAY $10
MILLION AND YOU CAN WIN A FREE
BET ANYWHERE FROM $10 TO $1
MILLION.
CHECK OUT DRAFT KINGS.DOCOM FOR
OFFICIAL RULES.
LET'S DIVE IN.
LET'S LOOK AT QUICK HITTERS AND
MAYBE YOU'RE WATCHING THE SUPER
BOWL WITH A FRIEND AND YOU OWE
HIM SOME MONEY AND YOU OWE IST O
HIM BY HALFTIME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
PROPS.
WE'RE TALKING COIN TOSS AND
OPENING KICK, A TOUCHBACK.
FIRST OFFENSIVE FROM SCRIMMAGE
AND OVER 7 1/2 AND THIS BOARD IS
LOADED, BUT FELLAS, I'M LOOKING
AT THAT LAST CATEGORY FIRST
TOUCHDOWN.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO OVER HERE AT
B.R. BETTING.
>> YES, SIR.
>> WE ARE LOOK FOR EXAMPLE
FUCHFUC
TOUCHDOWN SCORES OF THE GAME AND
COOPER CUPP AT THE TOP OF THE
BOARD AND JOE MIXON, CAM ACRES
AND THIS IS JUICY ODDS WITH
ODELL BECKHAM AT PLUS 900 AND
TIGHT ENDS WITH HIGBEE RIGHT
THERE, AS WELL.
SO, GREG.
WE HAVE THE BOARD.
WE NEED THE PEOPLE'S OPINION AND
LET THEM KNOW HOW YOU NEED AND
HOW CAN YOU WIN SOME OF THESE
GIVEAWAYS?
>> EVERYBODY THAT IS WATCHING.
EVERYBODY THAT'S IN THE
COMMENTS, LISTEN UP AND LISTEN
UP CLOSELY.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO USE YOUR
FINGERS.
USE THOSE TWITTER FINGERS,
INSTAGRAM FINGERS AND BLEACHER
REPORT FINGERS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US WHO IS
SCORING THE BIG TOUCHDOWN ON
SUNDAY AND I'M GIVING AWAY A
JERS, CONNOR.
>> YOU LOVE TO SEE IT, MAN.
STICK AROUND.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO LEAVE.
WE HAVE THE PHONE TO GIVE AWAY
AT THE END OF THE SHOW.
DK DOLLARS.
AQIB, YOU KNOW THEY LOVE THE
SPOTLIGHT AND LOVE THE
CELEBRATION AND GETTING IN ON
THE EARLY ACTION AND IT'S YOUR
JOB TO SHUT THEM DOWN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FAVORITES
AMONGST THIS GROUP FOR FIRST
TOUCHDOWN SCORE?
>> OOH, I'M LOOKING AT THIS
LIST.
I KEEP LOOKING AT HIGBEE AND I
DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT KNEE WILL
BE RIGHT AND I LIKE THE DOUBLES
TO GO TO ODELL AND COOPER CUPP
AND CHASE WILL GET IT AND I KEEP
GOING TO THESE RUNNING BACKS AND
I'M GOING GO CAM ACRES AND I
LIKE IT PLUS 750 AND I LIKE CAM
ACRES TO BE THE FIRST OF THE
GAME.
>> AQIB, I WOULD NEVER EXPECT
YOU TO GIVE THE WIDE RECEIVER
SOME LOVE.
I LIKE IT?
.
I'LL DO IT.
I'LL RIDE WITH ODELL BECKHAM AND
THERE'S A SPOTLIGHT ON JAMAL
CHASE AND THE FUTURE OFFENSIVE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AND ODELL HAS
BEEN SHINING SINCE HE GOT TO LOS
ANGELES AND HE IS AT HIS BEST
WHEN THOSE LIGHTS ARE BRIGHT AND
ODELL WILL PUT ON SOMETHING
SPECIAL FOR THE SUPER BOWL IN
THIS GAME.
HE MIGHT HAVE THE MORE FAVORABLE
MATCHUP, SO ODELL PLUS 900.
GREG, WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> ARE YOU ROLLING WITH THE RAMS
PICKS OR DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING
ELSE IN STORE?
>> I SEE RAMS TO MY LEFT AND I
SEE RAMS TO MY RIGHT.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT RUNNING BACKS
AND I LIKE THAT.
HE'S AN NFL LEGEND SO I'LL
PIGGYBACK ON AQIB, BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO TAKE ACRES AND I'M
TAKING MY MAN FROM THE BAY AREA
HIMSELF JOE, PLUS 750.
I LIKE THAT, BUT LET ME HOB INTO
THESE COMMENTS AND LET ME HOP
INTO THESE COMMENTS, AQIB, LET
ME HOP INTO THESE COMMENT,
CONNOR.
EVERYBODY IS STILL IN THE
COMMENTS GIVING US PREDICTIONS
ON WHAT THE SCORE WILL BE, AND
GREG, LOCK UP HIGGINS AND
THEY'RE TELLING ME I NEED TO
GIVE AWAY A JERSEY AND I SEE
ERIC WILLPOWER AND HE SAYS JOE
MIXIN, GREG.
L.A. GIVES UP A LOT OF END ZONE
RUNS AND ONE PLAY AND YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY OF
YOUR CHOICE AND YOU SEE WHAT HE
DID AND HE TOOK MY PICK AND THEN
GOT A JERSEY.
THAT'S HOW THINGS GO AROUND
HERE.
>> GOT TO BE SMART.
>> EXACTLY.
THE COMMENTS ARE ON TO THE MAN
WITH THE GIVEAWAYS.
THEY KNOW THAT.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF GREG LOVE
IN THE COMMENTS TODAY AND IF
YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING US ALL
YEAR, YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU ALSO KNOW OUR FAVORITE QUICK
HITTER IS THE NO SCORE FIRST
DRIVE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THROUGH DRAFTKINGS
ALL YEAR AND EVERY MONDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL THAT'S WHAT WE DO, AND
WE HAVE SOMETHING SPECIAL RIGHT
HERE.
POINTS ON THE FIRST DRIVE, FIELD
GOAL AND THE TOUCHDOWN.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, BOOSTED FROM
PLUS 150 TO PLUS 220.
SO GET IN ON THE FIRST DRIVE
ACTION.
THESE TEAMS COMING IN HOT AND IS
THE SUPER BOWL GOING TO BE A
SHOOTOUT EARLY ON OR IS THIS
GOING TO BE A FEELING OUT
PROCESS AND SLOW?
.
I THINK MY MAN AQIB MUTED
HIMSELF.
>> I CAN TELL YOU BASICALLY WHAT
I THINK HE WAS GOING TO SAY, BUT
I'LL GET MY PICK CONNOR BECAUSE
THE PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW I'M
GOING WITH NO SCORE FIRST.
NO SCORE, FIRST DRIVE.
I MEAN, DEFENSES WINS
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND THE DEFENSES
ARE GOING COME OUT AND I THINK
THEY'LL TRY TO MAKE A STATEMENT
EARLY AND WE SAW LAST WEEK AND
WE SAW LAST WEEK THE RAMS DIDN'T
SCORE IN THE FIRST POSSESSION
AND THE BENGALS DIDN'T SCORE IN
THE FIRST POSSESSION SO I'M
ROCKING WITH NO, MAN.
I'M ROCKING WITH NO, AND I HOPE
AQIB'S ROCKING WITH ME.
CONNOR, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
RIDING?
>> I'M WITH YOU, GREG.
FOR REAL.
I'M WITH YOU ALL OF THE WAY.
WE HAVE TO KEEP BACK.
I'M GOING NO POINTSES AND GREG
IS GOING NO POINTS AND I HEAR
AQIB, WE'LL GET HIM BACK BECAUSE
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT HE'S GOT.
SO, I HEAR HE'S BACK.
>> AQIB.
>> WELCOME BACK.
YOU'RE GOOD.
WHO WANTS THE PICK?
>> I'M DEAF NITSLY GOING NO.
AND I THINK THE DEFENSE WILL
COME OUT HOT AND BOTH OFFENSE
WILL KIND OF FILL OUT THE
DEFENSE AND SEE HOW THEY'RE
PLAYING AND I SEE WHERE JAYLEN
IS, AND I SEE HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO USE HIM.
>> I LIKE BOTH TO GET A STOP FOR
A DRIVE.
WE'RE EXPECTING NOTHING AND LET
ME TALK ABOUT THE COIN TOSS AND
A HOT TOPIC WITH THE SUPER BOWL.
GREG, IT'S TIME AND YOU'RE
SENDING OUT A STACK OVER THERE
AND YOU HAVE DK DOLLARS TO GIVE
AWAY.
LET THEM KNOW HOW THEY CAN GET
IN ON THIS ACTION.
>> CONNOR, THIS YEAR WE ARE
GOING ALL IN ON THE COIN TOSS.
YES, THE COIN TOSS.
SO I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL US WHETHER
YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO BE HEADS
OR TAILS AND AQIB TALIB'S YES
YOU, CAN BE WALKING AWAY WITH
250 DK DOLLARS AND CONNOR, WE
SAY THIS EVERY TIME WE GIVE AWAY
DK THERE ARES AND PLEASE PARLAY
THAT 250.
PLEASE PARLAY THE 250 SO YOU CAN
BUBBLE IT UP MORE AND MORE.DS A
250.
PLEASE PARLAY THE 250 SO YOU CAN
BUBBLE IT UP MORE AND MORE.OS A
250.
PLEASE PARLAY THE 250 SO YOU CAN
BUBBLE IT UP MORE AND MORE.LS A
250.
PLEASE PARLAY THE 250 SO YOU CAN
BUBBLE IT UP MORE AND MORE.LS A
250.
PLEASE PARLAY THE 250 SO YOU CAN
BUBBLE IT UP MORE AND MORE.ARS
THAT 250.
PLEASE PARLAY THE 250 SO YOU CAN
BUBBLE IT UP MORE AND MORE.
YEAH.
YOU ALL HAVE TO HAVE THE SAME
THING AS AQIB AND YOU'LL WALK
AWAY WITH $250.
>> BEFORE WE GET TO THAT, AND
GREG, I KNOW YOU'LL BE WATCHING
THESE COMMENTS CLOSELY.
CHECK OUT THE COIN TOSS FROM OUR
FRIENDS OVER AT DRAFT KINGS.
>> IN A HEADS OR TAILS
SITUATION, CALLING HEADS IS A
FIREABLE OFFENSE.
>> I HAVE A BIG HEAD.
I KNOW ABOUT BIG HEADS.
THEY WEIGH MORE.
IT'S SCIENCE.
>> IT'S FIRST GRADE STUFF.
>> I'M A TAILS GUY.
I ALWAYS GO TAILS.
>> IT WAS TAILS NEVER FAILS.
>> WE'RE GOING THE OPPOSITE WAY
AND HEADS ON THE COIN TOSS.
>> I'M ALSO TAKING HEADS ON THE
COIN TOSS.
>> TAILS.
>> I'M GOING HEADS.
>> GET IT?
BECAUSE THAT'S MI HEAD.
>> DON'T GET FIRED AND KEEP IT
SIMPLE.
>> ALL TAILS, GAME BLASTED.
>> MAKE SURE YOU BET ON THE BIG
GAME.
>> EVEN SPLIT.
HOW DID YOU DECIDE?
TAILS NEVER FAILS OR ARE YOU
ROLLING WITH HEADS ON THIS ONE?
>> TAILS NEVER FAILS, BABY AND
I'M NOT 100% SURE AND I'M
THINKING IN THIS KANSAS CITY
SITUATION WE JUST HAD.
I THINK KANSAS CITY PICKED TAILS
AND THENNED BINGALS AND THE
BENGALS LOST, BUT THEY PICKED
HEADS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU HEARD IT FROM HERE.
AQIB IS GOING WITH TAILS NEVER
FAILS AND WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS
GOING RIGHT NOW BEFORE YOU GIVE
AWAY THOSE BK DOLLARS?
>> CONNOR, LET ME HOP INTO THOSE
COMMENTS RIGHT HERE AND SEE WHAT
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT?
I'M GIVING AWAY SOME D.K.
DOLLARS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M GIVING
IT AWAY TO THE RIGHT PERSON.
J.G.276.
YOU ALREADY KNOW.
SHOUTS OUT TO YOU J.G. 276 AND
YOU WALK AWAY FROM THE HOODIE
AND SPICY ANGEL IS COME THE
COMMENTS SAYING TAILS EVERY DAY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, SPICY ANGEL.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE, BUT HOLD ON.
>> AND I'LL GIVE IT TO, AND MY
MAN AQIB LITERALLY JUST SAID IT
AND THEREFORE, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH THE 250 D.K. DOLLARS.
>> WE HAVE A LOT MORE FROM WHERE
THAT CAME FROM.
SO STICK AROUND IF YOU WANT TO
GET IN ON THE D.K. DOLLAR ACTION
AND WE HAVE A LOT TO GIVE AWAY
AND LET'S KEEP THIS MOVING AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT PLAYER PROPS
AND ONE OF THE MOST FAVORITE
MARKETS OF THE ENTIRE SUPER BOWL
AND RUNNING BACK HEAD TO HEAD AT
THE TOP RUSHING YARDS AND MY
FAVORITE RIGHT THERE THE WIDE
RECEIVER IS COOPER KUB FOR
RECEIVING YARDS AND SO THIS
BOARD ABSOLUTELY LOADED, FELLAS.
>> WHO ARE YOU TAKING ON THIS
WIDE RECEIVER?
COOPER CUPP WHO HAD A PHENOMENAL
YEAR OR THE PENDING OFFENSIVE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
>> BOTH OF THEM GOT TOP
RECEIVERS, MAN.
WO TWO GREAT RECEIVERS AND I
FEEL LIKE THE RAMS GOT A GUY WHO
CAN CONTAIN AND MAYBE STOP AND
ASK ME, I'M GOING TO SAY HE CAN
STOP THEM.
THEY'VE GOT A GUY, RIGHT?
THE NAME WHO GOT A STORE AROUND
HIS NAME ON MADDEN.
THEY HAVE A GUY WHO SAYS,
CINCINNATI GOT A GUY WHO CAN
STOP CUPP AND I'D LIKE HIM TO
PLAY A LOT OF ZONE UNTIL THE
RAM
RAMS SHOWED HIM HE CAN PLAY ZEN
AND I'M WITH COOPER CUPP.
>> AQIB IS RIDING WITH COOPER
CUPP RIGHT THERE ON THE HEAD TO
HEAD FOR MOST RECEIVING YARD PS
UPON LET'S KEEP IT MOVING HERE
AND MVP AND LET'S SEE THE MVP
ODDS FOR THE SUPER BOWL.
THE QUARTERBACK ALWAYS SIT AT
THE TOP OF THIS AND MATT
STAFFORD.
THERE IT IS AND JOE BURROW PLUS
225 AND THIS IS WHERE THE FUN
GETS STARTED AND A.D. PLUS 1600
AND THERE'S JAMAR CHASE AND
ODELL BECKHAM AND THEN IT GETS
OFF THE RAILS AND THE RUNNING
BACKS AND JOE NIXON.
SO, GREG, I KNOW THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD IS HEATING UP AND LET THEM
KNOW WHAT WE NEED RIGHT NOW?
>> WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO
IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
US WHO YOU THINK IS WINNING MVP
ON SUNDAY.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND I'M
ALSO GIVING AWAY A JERSEY THIS
WAY, CONOR.
AQIB, TALK US TO.
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO WIN MVP?
>> I SEE THEM ODDS AND IT'S NOT
A BAD BET, AND I'VE SEEN IT DEEP
AS A PLAYER THAT IS IN THIS GAME
AND I'VE SEEN THE TWO AND A HALF
SACK AND TWO FORCED FUMBLES AND
HE WENT CRAZY AND I THINK IF HE
CAN GET TWO SACKS OR ONE FORCED
FUMBLE AND A LOT OF PRESSURE AND
TWO SACKS AND YOU'RE DISRUPTING
THE GAME YOURSELF, AND I'M GOING
TO GO A.D., MAN AND PLUS 1800
AND THAT'S A GOOD BET.
>> I LIKE AQIB AND VON MILLER
WOULD WIN THIS AND IT WOULDN'T
BE THAT CRAZY AND HE'LL FEAST ON
THAT BENGALS AND OFFENSIVE LINE.
I'LL GO OFFENSE, BUT I WON'T GO
CHALK WITH THE DEFENSE.
I'M GOING TO STICK WITH ODELL
AND HE CAN CATCH TWO TOUCHDOWNS
WITH THAT ONE AND HE'S GOT A
LEGIT SHOT AND THAT'S MORE THAN
A BOLD BET AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S BIG-TIME JUICE.
SO KEEP GOING WITH A.D. PLUS
1600 AND I'M GOING WITH ODELL
BECKHAM AT PLUS 1800 AND WHERE
ARE YOU LOOKING AT THIS MVP ODDS
RIGHT NOW?
EVERYBODY DON'T THINK TOO HARD.
YOU GUYS GOT THE LONG SHOTS.
I'M GOING TO BE THE CHALK-EATING
WEASEL AND I'M NOT GOING TO BE
MAD AT IT BECAUSE THE MVP IS A
QUARTERBACK'S AWARD.
MATT STAFFORD PLUS 100.
GIVE ME MATT STAFFORD PLUS 100
AND I'M GIVING THAT ONE TO THE
BAY.
?
WH
WHY NOT?
LET ME HOP INTEREO THESE COMMEN.
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE AND THE
JERSEY.
M. KEMP 93 SAYS AARON DONALD IS
A LOCK AND YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE AND HE HAS A.D.
AND LET'S GO AND SHOUT OUT TO
U.K., AND NEXT ONE I SAY, CONNOR
AND I'M GIVING HIM THE JERSEY.
I'M GIVING THEM THE JERSEY.
KING12.
DEFENSE WINS CHAMPIONSHIPS WITH
AARON DONALD, DONALD.
SO I GUESS WITH AQIB'S PICK WITH
A JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
YOU'VE GOT ME OVER HERE THINKING
ABOUT THE A.D. PICK.
.
HE'S TWO FEET AWAY.
I JUST FEEL THIS ENERGY.
HE'LL BE ON SOME DIFFERENT STUFF
ON SUNDAY.
I'M WITH YOU, THERE.
>> I FELT THAT ENERGY.
>> WE SEE WHAT HE DID TO THAT
LINE AND AQIB LIKES A.D. AND THE
HIGH THAT HE WILL BE CHASING AND
WEIR LOOKING AT THE QUARTERBACK
AND HEAD TO HEAD PASSING YARDS
MATCHUP AND WE'LL GET TO THE
OVER UNDERS LATER.
BURROW IS THE PLUS MONEY HERE TO
HAVE MORE PASSING YARD AS AND L
HIM KNOW WHAT WE NEED AND NOT
LETTING YOU TAKE HOME ANY OF IT.
>> MAN, I WISH I COULD TAKE HOME
250.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO COME AND
TELL ME WHICH QUARTERBACK IS
THROWING FOR MORE YARDS IN THE
SUPER BOWL IF YOUR PICK MATCHES
MY MAN AQIB TALIB, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH 250 D.K.
DOLLARS AND YOU COULD WALK AWAY
AND I HAVE TO KEEP YOU FIRST.
>> WHO'S THROWING FOR MORE
YARDS?
AN
AND IT THE FAVORITE WITH
STAFFORD AND 120?
>> I THINK THE RAMS HAVE A DOG
DAY ON THE GROUND.
I THINK THEY RUN THE HECK OUT OF
THE FOOTBALL AND THEY GET OUT
EARLY AND BURROW GOT TO TURN IT
TO STAY CALM, JOE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO THROW THE BALL TO
COME BACK IN THE GAME SO I THINK
HE'LL THROW FORMORE YARDS.
>> THE COMMENT, RIDING WITH AQIB
OR ARE THEY GOING WITH THE
FAVORITE AND STAFFORD?
>> LET ME SEE, MAN.
LET ME SEE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
MAKE SURE I GET TO THE NEW
COMMENTS AT THE BOTTOM.
I'VE GOT KAY HART 22 SAYS JOE
BURROW.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU KAY HART?
YOU KNOW, KAY HART?
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH THE 250 D.K. DOLLARS AND
THAT SIMPLE AND THAT FAST AND
THAT QUICK.
>> SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
SOMETIMES THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO.
GET YOUR PICK IN, AND YOU MIGHT
COME ONLY WITH 250 D.K. DOLLARS
AND BE SURE TO CHECK OUT DRAFT
KINGS EVERY AFTERNOON AND
LEADING UP TO THE SUPER BOWL AND
THEY'RE OFFERING A NEW BIG GAME
SUPER BOOST AND THESE HAVE BEEN
CRAZY.
YESTERDAY AND IT WAS COOPER CUPP
AND THE TOUCHDOWN THAT WAS
BOOSTED AND THEY'RE DOING THE
SHOW AND DO NOT WALK AWAY AND
YOU CAN DO IT AFTER THE SHOW AND
JOE BURROW WILL THROW TWO
TOUCHDOWN PASSES AND BOOSTED TO
PLUS MONEY AND PLUS 100 TO THROW
TWO TOUCHDOWNS AND THE DAILY
SUPER BOOST IS ONLY A WAILABLE
BETWEEN 6:00 AND 9:00 P.M.
EASTERN AND GET ON DRAFT KINGS
AND NOW THROUGH SATURDAY AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE BOOSTS.
NEXT UP IS THE OVER UNDER PROPS.
I TEASED IT BEFORE AND NOW WE'RE
GETTING INTO IT AND TIMES THESE
ARE SIMPLE, FELL AS.
OVER UNDER IS SET AT 48 1/2
TOTAL.
WE HAVE AND THE TOTAL TOUCHDOWNS
AT FIVE AND A HALF, AND
INTERCEPTIONS AND FUMBLES AND
NOT JUST INTERSEMGZS AT TWO AND
A HALF AND THE AUDIENCE HAS SEEN
THE BOARD AND YOU'RE TAPPED IN
WITH THE COMMENTS AND HOW DO
THEY TAKE HOME A JERSEY RIGHT
NOW IN WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO
DO IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE OVER OR
UNDER 48 1/2 POINTS IN THE SUPER
BOWL ON SUNDAY.
AND GIVING AWAY JERSEY.
>> LET'S GET INTO THIS POINT
TOTAL RIGHT HERE SITTING AT
48 1/2 AND PRETTY STEEP IN THE
GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS AND WE
HAVE A SHOOTOUT ON OUR HANDS AND
IS THIS OVER ON THIS ONE?
THE DEFENSE COMES OUT HOT, MAN
AND THEY GET IT GOING SLOW AND
THEY CAN PICK UP, BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO END UP 30
TO 20.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY GET THERE.
I'LL SEE YOU MID-20s TO HIGH
TEENS SO I'M GOING TO GO UNDER.
>> I'M WITH YOU ALL OF THE WAY,
AQIB.
I'VE BEEN RIDING UNDERS MOST OF
THE YEAR.
IT'S BEEN A PRETTY GOOD FORMULA.
I THINK PEOPLE GET POINTS HAPPY.
THEY ROOT FOR POINTS AND THEY
THINK THE OVER AND IT'S
POST-SEASON AND THE DEFENSE
ROLLS OUT AND ARE YOU THINKING
WE HAVE A SHOOTOUT ON OUR HANDS
FOR THE SUPER BOWL.
>> MY HEART IS TELLING ME THE
UNDER, BUT MY MIND AND I'M GOING
TO GO WITH WHAT MY MIND IS
SAYING TAKE THE OVER.
WE KNOW ABOUT THESE OFFENSES AND
WE KNOW ABOUT BOTH OF THESE
OFFENSES AND THEY'VE BEEN THE
STAR POWER THAT EACH OF THEM
HAVE.
BUT I'M NOT SAYING IT WILL COME
TOWN TO TWO DEFENSE OF PLAYS
TOWARD THE END AND I SEE THIS
ONE BEING A SHOOTOUT, CONNOR.
I SEE THIS BEING A SHOOTOUT,
AQIB.
SUPERSTARS ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE
OF THE BALL, AND I SEE THEM
PUTTING UP NUMBERS, BUT LET ME
GET INTO THE COMMENTS BECAUSE
I'M GIVING OUT HOODIES AND I SEE
RICHIE 21.
RICHIE 21 HIS COMMENT WENT AWAY
AND 48 1/2 POINTS AND SHOUT OUT
TO YOU, RICHY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE AND INDERMAN, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE AND
IT'S TIME TO GIVE OUT THIS
JERSEY AND IT'S TIME TO GIVE OUT
THIS JERSEY AND I SEE BURROW TWO
TOUCHDOWNS AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT, BUT JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE ENGAGED YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY.
I'M GIVING IT OUT TO EVERYBODY,
CONNOR.
EVERYBODY IS ABLE TO WALK AWAY
WITH JERSEYS AND 250 D.K.
DOLLARS, WHOEVER.
FILL THEM COMMENTS UP AND YOU
COULD BE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OR 250 BK DOLLARS.
>> THE MAN LIKED THE BURROW
BOOST AND HE WAS LISTENING AND
HE'S SO LOCKED IN AND AS ANOTHER
BONUS, WE PARTNERED WITH DRAFT
KINGS TO OFFER JAMAR CHASE AND
TO RUSH OVER THREE AND A HALF
YARDS.
YOU GET UP RIGHT NOW AND TAKE A
COUPLE OF STEPS AND THAT'S ALL
JAMAR CHASE NEEDS AND IT IS AT
PLUS 120.
THAT IS A HELL OF A BOOST.
SO THE QUESTION REALLY IS, AQIB,
IS JAMAR CHASE GOING TO GET SOME
CARRIES IN THIS ONE?
>> JAMAR CHASE WILL GET A PLAY
WHERE THEY PUT THE BALL STRAIGHT
IN HIS HANDS, AND I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WILL BE A TURNAROUND THIS
WAY AND QUICK PICKS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THEM AND THEY'RE FROM
THE McVEIGH TREE.
SO THEY'VE DEFINITELY GOT THOSE
PLAYS IN AND I HAVE TO GO WITH
THE OVER, THOUGH, MAN.
IF YOU PICKS UP A FUMBLE, IT'S
TOO EASY, SO I'M GOING TO GO
OVER THERE.
>> I LIKE IT.
I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
JAMAR CHASE OVER THREE AND A
HALF YARDS AND THE PLUS 120.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO SOME OF THE
YES OR NO PROP, WE'LL HAVE THAT
BOARD UP PRETTY SOON.
>> GREG, YOU KNOW WHAT TIME IT
IS.
IT IS D.K. DOLLARS TIME AND LET
THE COMMENTS KNOW WHAT WE'VE GOT
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
>> I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME HOW
MANY TOTAL TURNOVERS WILL THERE
BE ON SUNDAY.
IF YOUR PICK MATCHES AQIB TALIB,
YOU CAN WALK AWAY WITH $25 TO
D.K. DOLLARS.
>> PARLAY THAT, CONNOR.
>> THAT'S ALWAYS THE RULE.
>> THAT'S THE RULE AT THIS
POINT.
DO YOU KNOW A THING OR TWO?
YOU KNOW A THING OR TWO ABOUT
MAKING A PLAY ON THE BALL IN THE
AIR AND WE'RE ASKING YOU RIGHT
NOW, TURNOVERS.
TWO AND A HALF.
WE'LL COUNT FUMBLES HERE AND
IT'S NOT JUST INTERCEPTIONS AND
HOW MANY TURNOVERS ARE YOU
PREDICTING IN THIS ONE.
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN GET THE
THREE OR THE QUARTERBACKS THAT
CAN GET CRAZY AT TIMES THAT WILL
KEEP THIS LOW.
>> I LIKE TO ABOUT OVER, AND I'M
GOING TO GO THREE, MAN, MAYBE
TWO INTERCEPTIONS AND ONE
INTERCEPTION ON ONE SIDE AND A
FUMBLE AND I'M THINKING THREE
TURNOVERS.
GREG, WHICH WAY ARE THE COMMENTS
LEANING?
DO THEY LIKE IT OVER FOR AQIB OR
UNDER AND ONE OF THOSE LUCKY
COMMENTERS WILL TAKE IN THE
PARLAY DOLLARS AND THE PARLAY
DOLLARS AND WE'RE ROCKING WITH
THE DEFENSE TAKE AND TAKE THE
OVER.
THERE IT IS.
THERE'S NO REASON TO KEEP GOING.
THERE'S NO REASON TO GIVE
SOMEBODY ELSE, AND AUSTINO,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH THE 250
D.K. DOLLARS AND THE SAME THING
AS MY MAN AQIB.
>> THAT SIMPLE.
>> IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> LET'S GET INTO THESE YES OR
NO PROPS AND FELLAS, THIS IS
WHAT I LIKE TO CALL THE MANIAC
BOARD AT THIS POINT.
THIS IS WHERE THINGS GET
ENTIRELY OFF THE RAILS WHERE
YOU'RE SAYING YOUR HAIL MARYS
AND OUR FATHERS AND WE GOT
RECOVERED ON-SIDE PICK AT PLUS
2500 THESE GET THE PROP TO WIN A
JERSEY RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY
WATCHING IN THE COMMENT, DROP
YOUR FAVORITE YES OR NO PROP AND
LOCKS IN THE COMMENTS AND GIVING
AWAY HOODIES AND I'M ALSO GIVING
AWAY A JERSEY.
CONNOR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> AQIB, I'VE GOT TO ASK.
YOU'VE SEEP THE BOARD DO YOU
LIKE ANY OF THESE?
INITIALLY I MISSED THE EXTRA
POINT, AND THEN, AND THE GUY WHO
AIN'T MISSED YET IN THE PLAYOFFS
AND I LIKE A TW-POINT CONVERSION
AND EVERYBODY GOING FOR TWO, AND
I LIKE THE TWO-POINT CONVERSION
AND I LIKE THE LAST PLAY ENDED
ON A DEAL.
I'M WITH YOU ON THE TWO-POINT
CONVERSION AND WE KNOW THE RAMS
AREN'T AFRAID OF THAT AND WE
KNOW ZAC TAYLOR AND THESE ARE
TEAMS THAT HAVE HAD TWO WEEKS TO
PRACTICE AND THE TWO-POINT
PACKAGE IS GOING TO BE REAL IN
THIS ONE WITH SOME KIND OF
SCENARIO.
SO I LIKE THAT A LOT, AQIB.
I'LL TAKE THAT ONE FROM YOU.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU HAVE GOING?
IS EVERYONE NUTS PREDICTING A
SAFETY OR OFFSIDEKICK?
>> I'LL HOP INTO THE COMMENTS,
CONNOR, I'LL JUST DROP MY LOCK
OR WHATEVER AND I'LL GO WITH THE
MIXED FIELD GOAL AND BUTTERFLIES
ARE GOING TO BE FLYING AND WE
HAVE A YOUNGSTER KICKING AND WE
ALSO HAVE A VETERAN OUT THERE
AND BUTTERFLIES WILL BE FLYING
AND WE'LL HAVE A MIXED FIELD
GOAL.
>> A BLOCK COUNT AS A MISS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I'M TRYING TO FIND -- OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
>> 100% WITH AQIB.
YOU CAN SEE ON THE SCREEN THE
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
>> SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE AND
BLUE 16 IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING NO SAFETY.
I THINK THAT WAS A LOT OF JUICE
AND I'M GIVING AWAY A JERSEY ON
THIS NEXT ONE AND I'LL GIVE A
JERS OAT NEXT ONE.
I'VE GOT H.H. JOHNSON SAYS
TWO-POINT CONVERSION.
DEUCES AND SHOUT OUT TO JOHNSON
101.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE PEOPLE HAVEEC INTOEN FOR THE
YES OR NO PROP, BUT BEFORE WE
MOVE ON, I WAS ABLE TO CATCH UP
WITH DRAFTKINGS' VERY OWN THE
LEGEND OF THE SPORTS BOOK JOHNNY
AVELLO.
>> VERY HAPPY TO WELCOME IN
JOHNNY AVELLO.
SPORTS BETTING HAS GONE LIVE IN
THE STATES OF LOUISIANA AND NEW
YORK THIS LAST MONTH WITH A
MARKET THAT IS ALWAYS, ALWAYS
GROWING.
IS THIS THE LARGEST SUPER BOWL
HANDLE WE WILL SEE SO FAR?
>> WELL, I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
OTHERS, CONNOR AND IT WILL BE
THE BIGGEST FOR D.K.
HERE'S MY EXPLANATORY
MEMORANDUM, AS YOU MAY SAY.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PLAYOFFS, WE HAD A RECORD
BREAKING HANDLE AND AS WE WERE
DOWN IN THE LAST WEEKS THE
HANDLE CONTINUES TO GROW SO I'M
LOOKING FOR A BIG ONE HERE.
>> YEAH.
I WOULD AGREE.
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS IT WILL BE
MASSIVE AND ALONG WITH THAT
COMES AN EXTENSIVE MENU.
DRAFT KINGS HAVE BEEN PHENOMENAL
OFFERING A TON OF DIFFERENT
PROP, NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
WHICH PROP IF YOU HAD TO PICK
ONE OR TWO, DO YOU THINK WOULD
BE THE MOST POPULAR THIS SUPER
BOWL?
>> THERE ARE MANY THAT I CAN PUT
IN THE MOST POPULAR BUCKET AND
THE SLASH ANY TIME SCORE WILL BE
AMONG THE MOST WIDELY BET.
>> YEAH.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF ACTION ON
THAT ALL YEAR WHICH OBVIOUSLY IS
A LITTLE BIT OF LUCK OR SKILL,
AND WITH THAT BEING THE MOST
POPULAR, WHICH WOULD BE THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO PRICE OVERALL?
>> CONNOR, TO BE HONEST, I DON'T
THINK ANYTHING IS TOO DIFFICULT
ANY LONGER.
I COULD TELL YOU THERE WERE A
LOT THAT WERE DIFFICULT TO PRICE
AND WE HAVE WEALTH AND KNOWLEDGE
AMONG THE WHOLE TRADING TEAM SO
THINGS AREN'T THAT DIFFICULT ANY
LONGER.
>> JOHNNY, YOU'RE A LEGEND IN
THIS SPACE AND THAT'S WHY I LOVE
HAVING YOU ON YOU'VE SEEN PLENTY
OF SUPER BOWLS FOR GOOD AND BAD
REASONS.
WHAT'S THE WORST SUPER BOWL BEAT
YOU'VE EVER WITNESSED?
>> OH, BY FAR, THERE IS ONE THAT
WILL ALWAYS STAND OUT.
>> I KNOW WHERE YOU'RE ANYTHING
AND THIS IS A BAD BEAT FOR THE
BOOKS AND ME IN PARTICULAR.
>> IT'S SUPER BOWL XLVIII AT
METLIFE STADIUM AND THEY'RE
BETTING WILL THERE BE A SAFETY
IN THE GAME AND THEY'RE BETTING
WILL IT BE A SAFETY AT 125 TO 1?
SO THE BRONCOS GET THE BALL
FIRST AND AFTER THE TOUCH BACK
AND THEY'RE FIRST AND TEN, AND
MANNY RAMIREZ HIKES IS OVER
PEYTON MANNING'S HEAD AND THERE
WE GO, SAFETY.
WE WERE STUCK 200K AFTER THE
FIRST PLAY AND WE RECOVERED THAT
DAY, CONNOR AND THEN THEY'LL
MAKE IT A FEW BUCK, BUT THE
BRONCOS DIDN'T D LOSE THE GAME
43-8.
>> THAT ONE WAS RIGHT IN MY BACK
YARD SO I REMEMBER IT VERY, VERY
VIVIDLY.
JOHNNY AVELLO FROM DRAFT KINGS
SPORTSBOOK, ALWAYS GREAT TO HAVE
YOU ON ESPECIALLY DURING SUPER
BOWL WEEK.
>> THANK YOU.
GREAT SEEING YOU.
>> A BIG THANKS TO JOHNNY.
LET'S TALK NOVELTY PROPS, AND
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT'S GATORADE, SHOWER, COLOR AND
MAYBE THE MOST POPULAR SUPER
BOWL DISCUSSION WHEN IT COMES TO
BETTING AND IT'S FUN DOWN HERE
AND I GOT A KICK TO HITS THE
UPRIGHTS AND PLUS 200 AND THAT
IS TOO LOW FOR ME AND THAT SEEMS
A LITTLE BIT BOLD AND WHEN
THINGS GET FUN AND THROW A
TOUCHDOWN PASS, PHILLY SPECIAL
IS WHAT WE'RE THINKING THERE AT
PLUS 1400.
NOVELTY PROPS MEANS NFL JERSEY
GIVEAWAY HERE.
WHAT I NEED EVERYONE TO DO IS
GETS IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHICH GATORADE COLOR WILL BE ON
THE WINNING COACH AND I'M GIVING
THIS ONE A JERSEY CONNOR.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT COLOR
GATORADE WILL HAVE, AND THE
COLORS AND FLAVORS AND WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT HERE AND
ORANGE IS THE FAVORITE ON THE
BOARD FOLLOWED BY EVEN FIELD AND
BLUE AS IN WATER AND YELLOW
GATORADE FOR THE FOLKS AT HOME.
IF YOU CALL IT GREEN GATORADE, I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
AQIB, WHO DECIDES THIS?
WHO HITSES THE GATORADE COLOR?
>> I GUESS THE TRAINING STAFF
AND THESE DECISIONS ARE MADE ALL
OF THE WAY IN TRAINING CAMP.
I'M SURE THEY PUT IN A HUGE
ORDER, WHATEVER GATORADE THEY'LL
USE FOR THE YEARS, RIGHT?
DIFFERENT TEAMS HAVE DIFFERENT
GATORADES AND SOME PLAYERS, WE
PUT IN SPECIAL REQUESTS FOR THE
GATORADES AND BEFORE I SEEN THAT
LIST I WAS KIND OF THINKING
ORANGE.
I WAS THINKING THAT WILL BE
ORANGE, BUT I NEVER WANT TO GO
WITH THE FAVORITE IN THAT
SITUATION, AND I DON'T WANT TO
GO WITH THE FAVORITE SO I'M
GOING GO BLUE.
I'LL GO TO THE SECOND ONE AND
I'LL GO WITH PLUS 400 AND GO
BLUE.
>> AQIB, YOU'RE A MAN THAT DOES
NOT MAKE THE CHALK PICKS AND
THAT'S WHAT I RESPECT WITH YOU,
AND I'LL GO HERE AND GO WITH THE
YELLOW GATORADE.
>> THAT'S PLUS 450.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF ORANGE GAIT
RID AND THERE'S A REASON WHY
IT'S AT THE TOP OF THE BOARD.
>> ME, RIGHT HERE.
I AM A MAN WITH THE CHOCK PECKS.
>> WITH THAT BEING SAID.
YOU'RE A MAN THAT MAKES MONEY.
>> I ALSO HAVE THE COLOR ON
ORANGE.
>> IT'S MY FAVORITE COLOR, AND
LET'S SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND I'M IN THE
HANDY DANDY iPAD AND I'M ALSO
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY, AS WELL.
>> I SEE DAN DUVAL 54 IS IN THE
COMMENTS ROCKING WITH PURPLE AND
THE SHOUT OUT TO YOU AND SHOUT
OUT TO ALL 54.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY AND I'LL
GIVE YOU A JERSEY AND YOU GAVE
US A GIFT AND I'LL GIVE AWAY TWO
HOODIES HERE, CONNOR, REAL QUICK
AND RED IS THE BEST COLOR SO
THAT'S WHERE IT IS AND SHOUT OUT
TO YOU AND YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE AND THINK, YOU HAD
TO SEE SOMEBODY THAT HAD MY
PICK.
JO JO, 4354 AND BENGAL LOCKED
AND THERE IT IS.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED OR
JERSEY.
>> JOJO WANTS THAT PARLAY MONEY.
HE WANTS TO PARLAY THE GATORADE
COLOR AND THE BENGALS LOCK.
GET ON DRAFT KINGS AND BET THE
NOVELTY PROPS AND WE'VE HAD OUR
FUN WITH THE PROPS AND WE LOOKED
AT EVERYTHING.
YES OR NO?
WE LOOKED AT THE OVER UNDERS.
WE LOOKED AT THE NOVELTIES AND
THE COIN TOSS.
GUYS, WE HAVE TO PICK WHO WILL
WIN THE GAME.
AT SOME POINT THIS IS WHAT IT
COMES DOWN TO AND SOMEBODY HAS
TO TAKE HOME THE LOMBARDI TROPHY
AND THAT MEANS SOMEONE HAS TO
TAKE HEM HOME THIS iPHONE 13 AND
YOU HAVE A CHANCE RIGHT NOW TO
TAKE HOME THE iPHONE.
LET'S TAKE ON THE CURRENT
CHAMPIONSHIP ODDS AND IT IS DOWN
TO TWO TEAMS AND YOU KNOW THEM
WELL.
THE RAM, THE FAVORITE MINUS 200
AND THE BENGALS AND THE
UNDERDOG, BUT ONLY AT PLUS 170.
GREG, THESE PEOPLE ARE CHOMPING
RIGHT NOW FOR THIS iPHONE.
TELL THEM WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
>> I NEED EVERYONE TO DROP YOUR
LOCK TO WIN THE SUPER BOWL AND
IF YOUR PICK MATCHES MY MAN AQIB
TALIB, YOU COULD BE WALKING AWAY
WITH THE iPHONE 13 THAT AQIB
SAID HE DON'T GOT, BUT CONNOR,
WORD AROUND TOWN IS -- NOT NOT,
THINK, ARE CONNOR, WORD AROUND
TOWN IS YOU ALREADY GOT ONE,
BRO, LIKE IS THAT TRUE?
AND I'LL BE PAYING THIS OFF FOR
A LONG, LONG TIME AND YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE LIKE ME BEING LOOKING
AT YOUR BILL EVERY MONTH GOING,
YEAH, I JUST HAD TO GET A NEW
PHONE AND I DIDN'T WANT ONE.
I GOT MADE FUN OF EVERYWHERE I
WENT WITH MY iPHONE 8.
>> I'LL JUMP IN AND MAKE MY
PREDICTION RIGHT HERE.
FELLAS, I HATE TO DO IT, BUT
IT'S ON THE RAMS AND THE BENGAL
MAGIC AND YOU WATCH THEIR
INTERIOR OFFENSIVE LINE ON TAPE
AND IT'S AMAZING THEY MADE IT
THIS FAR AND JEFFREY SIMMONS ON
THE TIGHT END AND HE HAD HIS WAY
AND HE COULD HAVE DONE ANYTHING.
>> YOU HEARD AQIB EARLIER AND HE
DOMINATES AND THEY HAVE THE
WEAPONS TO TEAR APART THE ZONE
DEFENSE AND I DON'T THINK THEY
CAN RUN WITH COOPER CUPP AND I
DON'T THINK THEY CAN RUN WITH
ODELL BECKHAM, AND I'M ROLLING
WITH THE RAMS AND GREG, OOUM
CURI
I'M CURIOUS TO GET YOUR TAKE AND
YOU HAVE A VENDETTA, AND I KNOW
YOU ALSO MAKE YOUR PICKS WITH
YOUR BRAIN AND NOT YOUR FANDOM.
>> THIS ONE'S TOUGH, BUT I AM A
REALIST, MAN.
I WAS ACTUALLY AT THE GAME LAST
WEEK AND I WAS DECKED OUT, AQIB
AND I HAD THE NINER HAT ON, BUT
WE DID NOT PULL IT OFF AGAINST
THIS RAMS TEAM AND IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO SAY AND I THINK THE LOS
ANGELES RAMS WILL GET IT DONE
AND THEY HAVE THE SUPERSTARS
INTACT ON THE DEFENSIVE SIDE OF
THE BALL AND THEY HAVE A GOOD
QUARTERBACK AND LIKE WE SAID IN
THE BEGINNING OF THE SHOW AND
AQIB SAID IT AND WE'RE ALL
SURPRISED THAT THE BENGALS ARE
HERE.
>> I WAS SURPRISED THAT THEY
BEAT KANSAS CITY IN KANSAS CITY.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE RAMS, MAN.
AND THEY'RE AT HOME, AQIB?
SO IT'S A HOME GAME IN CALI.
THEY'RE SLEEPING IN THEIR OWN
BEDS, COME ON, MAN.
IT'S WRITTEN UP FOR THE RAMS TO
WIN IN MY OPINION.
>> I'M ROLLING WITH THE RAMS.
AQIB, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
REMEMBER.
THE LAST TIME YOU WERE ON THIS
SHOW WAS -- IT WAS AUGUST.
IT WAS YOU, AND WE HAD VINCE
YOUNG.
WE HAD V.Y. ON THE SHOW.
>> I REMEMBER.
WE WERE TALKING FUTURES, WE WERE
TALKING ALL KINDS OF PRE-SEASON
BETS AND YOU GAVE US A PICK TO
WIN IT ALL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
YOU KNOW I HAVE TO PICK UP THAT
PAPER AND A DARK HORSE.
I'LL GO WITH THE BEST DEFENSE IN
THE LEAGUE, BABY.
I'LL GO WITH THE RAMS AND IF HE
CATCH FIRE IN THE DEFENSE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO,
THAT'S A GREAT BET, PLUS 1400?
COME ON NOW.
PLUS 1400?
>> HE GAVE IT TO YOU.
IN AUGUST, RAMS PLUS 1400.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I EVEN HAVE TO
ASK THIS, BUT AQIB, ARE YOU
STICKING WITH YOUR AUGUST PICK?
ARE THE RAMS WINNING THE SUPER
BOWL?
>> I CALLED HIM THE BEST
DEFENSE, WAY BACK IN AUGUST AND
THAT WAS BEFORE MY BROTHER WENT
OVER THERE, MAN, AND SO THEY
CRANKED UP EVEN MORE.
I HAVE TO RIDE WITH THE RAMS,
MAN.
I'M GOING TO RIDE WITH THE RAMS.
THEY'RE HUNGRY, MAN.
I LOOK AT THEM OVER THERE AND
THEY'RE HUNGRY, MAN, AND ODELL,
STAFFORD, I JUST THINK THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT GROUP OF VETS WHO ARE
HUNGRY AND THEY'LL LEAD THE
CHARGE, MAN AND IT'S GOING TO BE
THAT EFFORT, AND THE MORE HUNGRY
TEAM PLAY WITH JUST A LITTLE
MORE EFFORT IN THE SUPER BOWL,
AND THAT WILL GET HIM OVER THE
TOP, AND LAST TIME A TEAM PLAYED
A SUPER BOWL AT THE HOUSE THEY
WON EASILY.
SO -- YOU HAVE TO TRAVEL AND
TRAVEL IS BIG.
THE BUGS DON'T HAVE TO TRAVEL,
SO HEY, I'D LIKE THEM TO COME
OUT WITH THE ENERGY AND I'D LIKE
IT TO BE A HOME GAME FOR THEM
GUYS AND I'M RIDING WITH THE
RAMS.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE AWAY THE iPHONE
AT SOME POINT.
I'M SORRY.
>> I WOULD LET YOU KEEP IT, BUT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LET US TAKE
THAT PHONE, SO YOU HAVE TO GIVE
IT AWAY.
>> DON'T TELL EVERYBODY WHAT I
WAS TRYING TO DO, MAN.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
HOLD ONTO IT.
AND IT'S ALL GOOD.
MAKE THE QUICK BLEACHER REPORT
ACCOUNT AND GIVE MYSELF THE
iPHONE, BUT I'M IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW, MAN.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND THE
COMMENTS WANT TO JUMP.
THE LORD'S APPRENTICE SAYS THEY
HAVE THE FLEX ON THEM AND SHOUT
OUT TO YOU, SCOTTY AND HE LIKES
THE FLEX ON HIM, AS WELL AND
HERE WE GO.
BIG MIKE SAYS RAMS WIN, iPHONE
WIN AND THERE IT IS RIGHT THERE.
BUT HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
WE HAVE W. TRAMMEL.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S GOING
TO WIN IT, BUT HERE WE GO.
WE HAVE E-MONEY.
THEY ARE FAVORITE FOR A REASON
AND WE HAVE THE BEST WIDE
RECEIVER IN THE LEAGUE CUP AND
THE DEFENSE RONALD RAMSEY, AND
G-MONEY, GUESS WHAT?
WE ARE BLESSING YOU, MY MAN.
YOU SAID YOU NEED THE iPHONE SO
GREG IS GOING DELIVER.
WE ARE GIVING YOU THE iPHONE 13
AND HOPEFULLY THE RAMS REALLY
COME THROUGH AND WIN THIS FOR US
AND WE ARE ROCKING WITH YOU AND
WE ARE ALL ON THE RAMS AND LET'S
GO, MY MAN AND I'VE GOT TO GET
TO THE STORE, AQIB.
I HAVE TO GO GET ME ONE, MAN.
>> I NEED AN UPGRADE, BABY.
WHY NOT?
>> OH, MAN.
THE ACCOUNTS ARE RUNNING REAL
GOOD RID NOW OR SHOULD HAVE BEEN
AND SHOUT OUT TO E-MONEY TAKING
ON THE iPHONE 13 AND E-MONEY
LOOKING AT AQIB.
I KNOW ONE OTHER PERSON THAT'S
HOPING AQIB'S RAMS DO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL.
THAT'S OUR FRIEND MILLION DOLLAR
MARCO WHO BAEFSHGLY HAS A
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE LINE WITH
THE FUTURE TICKET AND IT'S
SIMPLE, MY MAN RIGHT HERE BET
OVER 100K ON THE RAMS AND YOU
SEE IT RIGHT THERE.
YOU SEE THE DATE.
OCTOBER 22nd, HE BET ON THOSE
RAMS AT PLUS 850 TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL AND NOT MAKE THE
SUPER BOWL AND BECAUSE OF THAT,
YOU CAN TAKE HOME OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS $1.1 MILLION AND AQIB,
TO CASH OUT IS 6 H
00,000 AND
CAN WALK AWAY WITH HALF A
MILLION DOLLAR PROFIT.
WOULD YOU LET THIS RIDE AND HIT
THE CASH OUT BUTTON?
NO COWARDS ON THIS SHOW?
DID YOU HEDGE IT?
WHAT WOULD YOUR PLAY BE HERE?
>> OH!
>> IT'S GOING TO BE HARD FOR ME
NOT TO HIT THAT CASHOUT, YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> WE'RE TALKING 500 AND THIS IS
A BETTING WORLD AND WE'RE MIXING
WITH DRAFT KING, RIGHT?
KEEP THE MINUTE OWE THE TABLE?
WE'RE ALMOST THERE, BABY.
AND HEY -- KEEP THE MONEY ON THE
TABLE, BABY.
WE NEED TO PICK UP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU HEARD HIM.
>> AND WE WANT TO HEAR YOU,
EVERYONE.
TELL MARCO WHAT YOU THINK HE
SHOULD DO.
I THINK HE SHOULD LISTEN TO
AQIB, HONESTLY AND TUNE INTO
MILLION DOLLAR MARCO'S AT 6:00
P.M. EASTERN TIME.
GOOD LUCK.
I WOULD BE SWEATING AND MARCO
WILL DECIDE HOW TO PLAY HIS
FUTURE AND WE'LL BE GIFRPING OUT
MORE HOODIES AND MORE PRIZES.
FELL AS, THAT'S A WRAP.
CONGRATS TO THE WINNERS AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMENTERS AND
A SPECIAL THANKS TO OUR GUY,
AQIB TALIB FOR JOINING THE SHOW.
IT'S BEEN GREAT HAVING YOU ON.
>> THANKS, GUYS, MAN.
I ALWAYS ENJOY THIS, MAN.
I'M DONE PLAYING SO I GET TO GET
INTO THIS BETTING WORLD, AND I
BETTER CALM DOWN, MAN, BECAUSE
I'M HITTING RID NOW.
>> KEEP THOSE GOOD VIBES GOING.
ALL RIGHT, EVERYONE.
GET IN AND CHECK OUT.
YOU SAW HIM HERE.
YOU HAVE CUSTOM PROPS.
THERE ARE DRAFT KINGS PROMOS AND
THEY'RE INSANE WITH JAMAR CHASE
AND THREE AND A HALF RUSHING
YARDS AND JOE BURROW, THE
CLOCK'S TICKING AND YOU STILL
HAVE TWO HOURS ON THE EASTERN
TIME ZONE AND PLUS 100 FOR TW
TOUCHDOWNS AND THE FIRST DRIVE
BOOSTER.
WE HAVE EVERYTHING AND ON THAT
NOTE, LET'S GET OUT OF HERE AND
ENJOY YOUR WEEKEND AND YOUR
WEEKEND, EVERYBODY AND GOOD LUCK
WITH YOUR TICKETS AND WE WILL
SEE YOU ON SUNDAY FOR A SPECIAL
SUPER BOWL SQUAD ROD AT 11:00
A.M. EASTERN SUNDAY MORNING.
♪